a seductive stranger with a stack of
Secrets a mysterious mansion and an
aspiring American author all feature in
director Guillermo del Toro's Gothic
romance crimson peak I'm Jan and this is
10 things you probably didn't know about
crimson peak director Guillermo del Toro
wrote 10 page character biographies for
Jessica Chastain Mia Wasikowska and Tom
Hiddleston the in-depth biographies
included details such as the characters
upbringing relationships with their
parents favorite smells and secrets all
of which del Toro told each actor to
keep to him or herself the information
not only helped the stars prepare for
their roles but also ensured they were
on the same page as del Toro when it
came to understanding their characters
actions influences and motivations when
Tom Hiddleston replaced Benedict
Cumberbatch in the role of Thomas Sharpe
Guillermo del Toro rewrote the script
according to del Toro before Hiddleston
joined the crimson peak cast Thomas was
originally going to be a much colder
character on top of del Toro's character
biography Hiddleston found inspiration
in a series of mood boards created by
costume designer Kate Hawley which he
placed around his trailer during filming
the boards included pictures of English
poet Lord Byron
Victorian engineers and miners and a
painting called wander above the sea of
fog by German Romantic artist Caspar
David Friedrich when del Toro first sent
Jessica Chastain the script for crimson
peak he assumed she'd want to play the
main character Edith an aspiring
American author but Chastain was more
interested in the role of the mysterious
antagonist Lucille who is the sister of
Tom Hiddleston's character Thomas
crimson peak was a tough shoot for
Chastain as not only did she have to get
into the dark headspace necessary to
play Lucille but she was also filming a
most violent year at the same time so
when it was time to shoot an especially
adrenaline charge scene del Toro
suggested Chastain drinks several large
expressos to get in the right mood oh
and by the way Chastain also learned to
play the piano for the film
not long after Charlie Hunnam finished
filming Pacific room with Guillermo del
Toro the director sent Hunnam an email
asking him to star in crimson peak from
then on in Hahnemann del Toro worked
together to create a biography for
Helm's character a young American doctor
called Alan McMichael the one thing del
Toro wasn't keen on that Hunnam
suggested was that dr. McMichael should
be a pipe smoker
according to Hunnam the reason was that
del Toro didn't want to add pipe smoking
to the list of things he had to fight
the studio to get on screen the movies
ghosts were played by actors Doug Jones
and Javier BOE Ted whose physical
presence on set really helped the movie
bleeds as it gave them something real to
react to the transparent look of the
ghost was later added with CGI Jones and
Boat s have both brought a number of
creatures to life in Del Toro's previous
productions including Pan's Labyrinth
Hellboy
and mamma to bring to life the Gothic
mansion al-adel Hall aka crimson peak a
huge set was built at Pinewood Toronto
Studios it took six months to design and
build a three and a half story set which
not only had a working elevator but also
functioning fireplaces the mansion's
rooms were linked by hallways which
meant the camera could move seamlessly
around the house and del Toro could
avoid having to digitally stitch scenes
together in post-production the only
room that wasn't connected to the main
mountain set was the bedroom one of the
only parts of the house that needed
green-screen was a hole in the ceiling
in order to show the sky although the
mansion's floor looks like it's made of
wood it was actually made of a specially
strong concrete so it could withstand
the volume of crew moving about
throughout the shoot the crimson peak
mansion is Del Toro's favorite set so he
was particularly sad when it had to be
taken apart after filming some of the
pieces of furniture made for the movie
were built in two different sizes one
bigger and one smaller
so when del Toro wanted to emphasize the
fact that a character was weak in a
particular scene they used the larger
size furniture on the set however if he
wanted to make the character appear
stronger he'd used the smaller version
of the piece of furniture
the word fear and the motif of
butterflies versus moths a hidden
throughout the design of a house
including in the custom-made wallpaper
del Toro has been fascinated by
butterflies and moths since he was a
child and used them to elude the
differences between the films two main
female characters Lucille and Edith
when del Toro and his co-writer Matthew
Robbins were penning the crimson peak
script they're inspired by an array of
novels including Emily Bronte's
Wuthering Heights Charles Dickens great
expectations Daphne du Maurier's Rebecca
Charlotte brontë's Jane Eyre and one of
Del Toro's favorite gothic novels Joseph
Sheridan a fan whose uncle Silas
in fact the character mia wasikowska
plays in crimson peak is named Edith
after American author Edith Wharton
whose novels include the age of
innocence and given del Toro's Lover
Frankenstein and the fact that author
Mary Shelley is mentioned in the film
it's quite possible that Edith's surname
Cushing is a reference to actor Peter
Cushing who played Frankenstein in many
Hammer horror movies now let me know in
the comments below which are your
favorite Guillermo del Toro movies and
one of the spookiest stories you've seen
on screen if you enjoyed this video do
please share it hit the thumbs-up button
and subscribe for more things you didn't
know as well as movie reviews and
interviews thanks for watching and see
you next time you be going movie lovers
you